hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
leader writers for the observer and
telegraph sonia soda and tim stanley so
very good to see both
and they're going to be taking us
through all the top stories from now
until midnight so first of all before we
chat then let's take a look at what's
making the front pages and the eye leads
with the news that the queen will not be
attending the cop 26 climate summit in
glasgow next week having taken medical
advice
it's something she deeply regrets
according to the front page of the daily
mail
a thundering wake-up call for the world
with warnings of a 2.7 degree celsius
temperature rise if countries fail to
act that's the lead story for the
guardian
rishi sunax expected to use up to 30
billion pounds from the proceeds of
economic growth to invest in public
services
tomorrow's budget makes the front of the
times
the metro highlights the chancellor's
wardrobe choices while being
photographed preparing for his speech
tomorrow describing them as new age we
will be talking about that story
the telegraph carries the findings of a
report which calls the 37 billion pounds
of funding spent on the covid test and
trace scheme eye watering given it
didn't bring about the return to
normality the government desired
according to the financial times the
government is aiming to raise enough
funds to block china from involvement in
the uk's nuclear energy plans by front
loading the cost onto consumers bills
and the star criticizes the actress
joanna lumley for suggesting a return to
wartime style rationing
so sonia soda and tim stanley i'm very
pleased to say are here with me tonight
hello properly to both of you
so first of all you've picked out the
eye at sonja and one of several of the
papers that put this on their front page
at some point
queen pulls out a cop 26 on doctor's
advice disappointment we're told for the
queen but i imagine disappointment as
well for boris johnson the hosts of
cop26
yeah i'm sure it's hugely disappointing
for both of them but the queen is 95.
she spent a night in hospital last week
and she's been advised by her doctors
only to undertake like duties and you
know the rounds trip to glasgow doesn't
fall into that category
so i'm sure she's really disappointed
i'm sure the prime minister will be
disappointed but i don't think that this
will detract too much
from the huge significance of um what's
going on in glasgow it's really i know
we're going to be talking about the sort
of substance of the climate story later
but it's a massively important moment
for world leaders coming together
to figure out a plan and to make
commitments in order to reduce the
extent of of global heating
um so i think it's you know i think it's
completely understandable it's on health
grounds i don't think anyone would be
expecting the queen to travel up to
glasgow um if her doctors are advising
her not to it's right that she rests um
but i i also don't think it will make
too much difference diplomatically to
the real meat of what's getting um what
needs to be agreed at the summit
tim do you agree with that i'm sure you
agree that the queen's health should be
the priority but what about her impact
on events like this i mean many people
do consider a bit of a star turn a lot
of the world leaders love the
opportunity to meet her
what effect can she have in these kind
of scenarios
a great deal i think and i'm sure that
the royal family will continue to
exert their usual kind of soft diplomacy
she is going to record a video message
so she will be felt there in spirit she
is 95 as has just been said
i sometimes struggle to go to london in
the morning so i wouldn't want to send a
95 year old whatever condition they're
in up to glasgow i don't think it's
unreasonable for her to stay and these
things can now be done remotely uh yeah
the royal family does exercise a certain
amount of moral political pressure upon
world leaders
when we have the uh the big global
investment summit last week everyone was
thrilled to be able to go to windsor
castle to meet the queen there the royal
family is very important but i have to
say i don't i suspect that the queen's
non-attendance is probably less
significant than the non-attendance of
president xi of china
right
uh china this year is looking to produce
more coal than ever before in order to
make up for power cuts you really need
china to be at the heart of cop 26 and
if you can't get beijing on board with
whatever everyone agrees uh next week in
glasgow it doesn't really amount to as
much as western leaders would like
let's move on shall we to the budget now
because obviously tomorrow is is a big
day with rishi sunak due to deliver his
budget um sonia the
several of the papers go with this not
for the first time over the last few
days and the telegraph story suggests
that um rishi sunak will start building
for life after
covid so
what's that what's their angle on this
well i think there's always two things
you've got to look for with a budget the
first is the chancellor's narrative
and his spin on the figures and what he
wants the world to look at his budget
and see
and the second is the reality of what's
going on and what the figures actually
say and the detail of the announcements
for example whether spending announced
is new or whether it's a reheated
announcement and so i think what's
interesting about this budget is we've
got all the papers sort of briefing on
the fact that sunak is going to be going
big on optimism and an age of optimism
and that is very much what he wants
people to take away from the budget and
i think some of the stories that have
been trailed in the run-up to tomorrow
definitely sort of show that that's his
spin on it so things for example like
saying that the public sector pay freeze
will be lifted um but the devil is in
the detail the country face a cost of
living crisis
um
you know millions of low-income families
have lost um just over a thousand pounds
a year because of the universal credit
card that comes in the decades of of
taxed
a decade of cuts to tax credits um for
low-income families with children that
have seen some families lose thousands
of pounds um it's true that it's been
brief that there's going to be an
increase in the minimum wage um but that
will barely that won't cover i mean the
maximum you can get back from that if
you're a low-income worker working
full-time after tax and uh universal
credit detections it's just under 300
pounds and you know families have lost
um a thousand pounds we've also got
energy and food prices rising so i think
there's a real disjunct here between the
optimism that the chancellor is trying
to convey um understandably some might
think in terms of a political spin
and the reality on the ground which is
that if you are a parent in low paid
work the next few months is going to
feel really really grim in light of the
cuts to things like universal credit but
also the um
the increase in the energy price cap
that's going to hit you um next april
rising food prices um rising energy
prices more generally
so i think there is a bit of a disjunct
here between the note that the chance is
trying to strike and the reality on the
ground for millions of low-paid parents
do you think that's right tim because
the guardian also picks up with this um
the message he wants to send out ahead
of the budget at least chancellor to
strike bullish note in budget i mean
he's talking about a post-covet economy
some would say we're not post covered
yet and there are those challenges
aren't there there is that that squeeze
that a lot of people are feeling at the
moment that sonja was talking about how
difficult is this going to be for him to
create a feeling of optimism
the interesting question the
anticipation is what is going to be the
big thing he will announce tomorrow
they'll be even more bullish and
optimistic than everything else he's
been
quietly dripping through the press since
september
this has been an incredibly well
well-trailed budget
with bits of good news coming out over
the course of weeks and in fact mps in
the commons today were expressing their
anger at that because that's not what
you're supposed to do in 1947 the
chancellor of the xeka hugh dalton
inadvertently gave away some budget
details to a journalist they appeared in
a newspaper and dalton had to resign
whereas nowadays as i said you can
actually trail your budget in advance
for weeks
and crucially looking back on it now
this was actually quite clever he also
trailed the pain in advance by telling
us that national insurance would go up
in order to pay for the nhs and social
care and that's the thing to bear in
mind there's a lot of stuff which is
going to come out of this which will be
optimistic people will be very pleased
to hear about things like the increase
in the minimum wage increase in spending
the nhs et cetera et cetera but we do
also face a cost of livings crisis which
in many ways is about the bill the tab
and the long-term economic effect
of the lockdown and we're going to be
paying for that some time to come so by
april of next year whatever goodies
you've got out of tomorrow's budget
april of next year people are going to
be hit by a rise in national insurance
they're probably going to be hit by a
rising council tax interest rates are
almost certainly going to go up so i i
think this has been politically very
well staged and managed i expect
tomorrow he's going to say things are a
lot better than you people thought they
were and and it may well look like that
in in the light of the budget but in the
weeks to come with all those tax
increases plus of course uh the the
reversal of that initial rise in
universal credit i suspect actually
people are in for significant amounts of
pain over winter that on top of all of
that could also add shortages of goods
and rising costs of fuel so he might be
bullish and optimistic i'm not so sure
that voters and consumers will be this
time next year yeah well it's going to
be interesting isn't it and let's
quickly take in the metro before we go
to the break because um not only have we
had various releases about what's going
to be in the budget we've also had a
release of i mean it's traditional isn't
it sonia we get a picture of the
chancellor working away on his budget
speech but um i i was convinced that the
pictures of him with his dog were going
to make the front pages but no it's his
sandals or his sliders that's getting
the attention in the metro
yeah it's his style choices a choice of
uh sandals and uh socks um i mean i have
to be you're absolutely right anna it is
traditional that the the chancellor
releases a photo or two in advance uh on
budget eve and that these are often the
focus of conversations uh in the press
um i have to confess so i i couldn't
care less what he wears
as he's preparing his budget speech i'm
much more interested in what he's going
to say and how that measures up against
the reality of what families are going
to be facing
tim
i remember george osborne had the byron
burger to show that he was working he
was he was eating while he was working
so he was so busy he couldn't even go
out to eat
whereas rishi looks like he's getting
ready for a sleepover i wouldn't be
surprised that he and his civil servants
spent the night doing each other's hair
it's a very laid-back look but that's
always the impression he's trying to
give he's an effortless man effortlessly
brilliant and good-looking and he's
going to give us an effortless budget
tomorrow as well i'm sure well we had
pictures of his pet and his snacks as
well so there are plenty of pictures to
pour over if anyone's interested we are
going to take a break right there lots
more to talk about are coming up very
shortly including was the kovid test and
trace scheme worth its billions of
pounds in funding we're going to be
talking about that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview uh with me tonight going through
the papers are sonia soda and tim
stanley
and tim we're kicking off this section
uh with the front page story of the
daily telegraph test and trace
criticized this eye-watering waste of
cash and this is an mp's report isn't it
what do they say
that's correct i'm going to have to
actually hold up my phone because some
of the figures are very precise i don't
want to get them wrong it reveals that
an extraordinary 37 billion pounds was
spent on this which is the equivalent of
around a fifth of the nhs's total budget
around 2 000 consultants were hired some
of them employed of rates on rates of
more than a thousand pounds a day at
some points uh there was only 11 of them
actually doing anything
uh the figure never got beyond 49
at the point at which test and trace was
most needed the system buckled and many
people did not get a test within 24
hours
um only a fraction of the several
hundred million tests that were sent out
were actually registered and of course
it failed in its key objective which was
to avoid the lockdown over the winter
so having wasted this extraordinary
amount of money on test and trace the
question is what is the future of the
program and what is the rationale for
such a program when we have the vaccine
it's an example of how extraordinary
decisions were taken in the last 18
months and they have to be accounted for
the idea that you can brush this under
the topic by saying it was a wartime
style situation we had to make uh big
decisions fast and
they weren't all going to be perfect
well fair enough but ultimately money
was wasted time was wasted and that this
was clearly a policy mistake and there
has to be some consequence for that yeah
an interesting timing isn't it when
we're talking about the chances that are
weighing out what kashi's got to play
with tomorrow i'm going to move this on
if that's all right it's on you because
there's a story on the front of the
guardian that would be nice to try and
squeeze in before we go to the end of
the program their main story focuses on
the un report the latest in a string of
un reports um
talking about the warnings for global
warming saying that we're on track at
the moment given global pledges of
temperatures of 2.7 degrees way above
the desired 1.5 degrees of global
warming
yes that's right so
part of this new report from the un is a
you know figure that we've been living
with for a long time which is that if we
want to prevent catastrophic
irreversible climate change of the sort
that we'll see millions of people at
display so really really terrible uh
consequences by the end of this century
we have to limit global heating to well
below two degrees centigrade and we've
got a global target of 1.5 and this is
the un you know the u.n sort of
periodically releases really grave
warnings on this this is u.n saying that
at current rates we're headed for 2.7
degrees by the end of the century